>> Announcer: THIS IS CNN
BREAKING NEWS.
>> YOU ARE LIVE IN THE "CNN
NEWSROOM," JIM ACOSTA IN
WASHINGTON, LAST-DITCH EFFORTS
TO AVOID A RUSSIAN INVASION OF
UKRAINE OFFICIALS IN THE U.S.
SAY COULD BEGIN AT ANY TIME.
PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD BE ONE OF
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL PHONE
CALLS OF HIS PRESIDENCY, A
62-MINUTE PHONE CONVERSATION
WARNING VLADIMIR PUTIN ABOUT
SPARKING A WAR THAT COULD
PRODUCE WIDESPREAD HUMAN
SUFFERING IN EUROPE.
A SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
TELLS CNN RUSSIA MAY ATTACK
ANYWAY.
OTHER WORRYING SIGNS THE U.S.
BELIEVES DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS
COULD BE IN VAIN.
THE U.S. SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
HAS TAKEN SOME U.S. FORCES OUT
OF UKRAINE MOVING THEM ELSEWHERE
IN EUROPE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS ORDERED
ALL NON-EMERGENCY STAFF TO LEAVE
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN KYEV AND
MAKING PERSONAL PHONE CALLS TO
OTHER AMERICANS IN THE COUNTRY
WARNING IT IS PAST TIME TO GET
OUT AND NO ONE IS COMING TO
RESCUE YOU IF UKRAINE BECOMES A
COMBAT ZONE.
RUSSIA HAS UKRAINE SURROUNDED ON
THREE SIDES, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
AN INVASION LIKELY BEGIN WITH
AERIAL BOMBING, MISSILE ATTACKS
AND A RAPID ASSAULT ON KYEV,
POTENTIALLY DURING THE OLYMPICS.
CNN IS COVERING EVERY ANGLE OF
THE CRISIS.
KYLIE ATWOOD AND ARLETTE SAENZ.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
PHONE CALL BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN?
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THAT JUST TOOK
PLACE.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A HIGH
STAKES CONVERSATION BETWEEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
SAYS THERE WAS NO FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGE TO THE DYNAMIC UNFOLDING
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF RUSSIA
INVADING UKRAINE APPEARS TO BE
INCREASING.
THE OFFICIAL DESCRIBES THE
CONVERSATION AS PROFESSIONAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE BUT SAID RUSSIA MAY
MOVE FORWARD WITH A MILITARY
ATTACK ANYWAYS.
THE PHONE CALL BETWEEN BIDEN AND
PUTIN LASTED JUST OVER AN HOUR.
THE PRESIDENT HOLDING THAT
SECURE CALL FROM CAMP DAVID AND
I WANT TO READ A PORTION OF THE
WHITE HOUSE STATEMENT REGARDING
THAT CALL.
THE PRESIDENT WARNED THERE WOULD
BE SEVERE COSTS IMPOSED ON
RUSSIA IF IT MOVES FORWARD WITH
AN INVASION AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
REITERATED A FURTHER RUSSIAN
INVASION OF UKRAINE WOULD
PRODUCE WIDESPREAD HUMAN
SUFFERING AND DIMINISH RUSSIA'S
STANDING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS CLEAR WITH
PRESIDENT PUTIN THAT WHILE THE
UNITED STATES REMAINS PREPARED
TO ENGAGE IN DIPLOMACY IN FULL
COORDINATION WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS WE ARE EQUALLY PREPARED
FOR OTHER SCENARIOS.
THE U.S. AND ALLIES ARE WORKING
ON A PACKAGE OF SANCTIONS
IMPOSED AGAINST RUSSIA IF IT
MOVES FORWARD WITH AN INVASION
AND COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
UKRAINE WITH SOME DEFENSE
CAPABILITIES TO TRY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
WE'VE SEEN THE U.S. PLANNING AND
DEPLOYING THOUSANDS OF TROOPS TO
NEIGHBORING POLAND OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS PAST WEEK, OF
THOSE EFFORTS TO PUT MILITARY
POSITIONING, IN EASTERN EUROPEAN
NATO ALLY COMPANIES IN AN EFFORT
TO BOLSTER NATO ALLIES OF THE
U.S. MADE CLEAR THEY WILL NOT BE
SENDING AMERICAN TROOPS INTO
UKRAINE.
THE U.S. ALSO TRYING TO PROTECT
AMERICAN INTERESTS IN THE
COUNTRY EVACUATING MOST OF THE
NON-EMERGENCY PERSONNEL AT THE
U.S. EMBOSSY IN KYEV.
THEY'VE WARNED AMERICANS NEED TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY IMMEDIATELY
THIS WEEKEND, AS THE SECURITY
SITUATION COULD CONTINUE TO
DEVOLVE IN THE COMING DAYS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THESE
NEXT STEPS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SAID, THE
HOUSE SAYS IN THAT CALL
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE AND HIS
TEAM WILL REMAIN IN CONTACT WITH
RUSSIA OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PAST FEW DAYS.
THE WHITE HOUSE HOPING DIPLOMACY
COULD HELP LEAD TO DE-ESCALATION
BUT IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THAT
MIGHT BE POSSIBLE IF PUTIN
DECIDES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH AN
INVASION WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYS THEY DO NOT HAVE FULL
VISIBILITY ON IN HIS CURRENT
THINKING AND WHETHER HE'LL MAKE
THE DECISION TO DO THAT.
>> ARLETTE THAT WAS VERY MUCH.
NIC, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
THE KREMLIN?
I SUPPOSE MORE DENIALS, MORE OF
THE SAME?
>>Y, YES, THAT SUMS IT UP,
DOESN'T IT.
THE DIPLOMATIC DIALOGUE MHAS NO
SHIFTED.
HIS SPOKESMAN FOR THE DEPUTY IN
THE OFFICE THE CONVERSATION CAME
FROM A POSITION OF HYSTERIA OF
THESE ACCUSATIONS THAT RUSSIA IS
ABOUT TO INVADE UKRAINE.
I THINK THE CENTRAL THEME FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PRESIDENT
PUTIN FROM THE RUSSIAN
PERSPECTIVE WAS TO REITERATE
THEY HAVE NOT HAD THEIR CORE
ISSUES ADRESSED WHICH IS TO DENY
UKRAINE ACCESS TO NATO AND INAT
TO GO BACK TO THE 1997 POSITION.
PRESIDENT MACRON HEARD A VERSION
OF THAT WHEN HE SPOKE TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN, SECRETARY OF
STATE ANTONY BLINKEN HEARD THAT
WHEN HE SPOKE WITH SERGEY LAVROV
THE FOREIGN MINISTER.
I THINK THE TWO OTHER THREADS
THAT CAME OUT OF TODAY WAS RUSH,
IN THE SORT OF ANTONY
BLINKEN/LAVROV CALL AND THE
PUTIN/MACRON CALL, RUSSIA TRYING
TO PUT PRESSURE ON THE UNITED
STATES, ON FRANCE, JEREMY
GERMANY AND OTHERS TO PUT
PRESSURE ON UKRAINE TO COMPLY IN
THEIR VIEW WITH THE MINSK
AGREEMENT, TO GET TALK WITH THE
RUSSIAN-BACKED PRO SEPARATISTS,
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
SO THERE WAS THAT PRESSURE
COMING FROM RUSSIA ON THAT.
THE OTHER PRESSURE FROM BLINKEN
TO LAVROV AND MACRON TO PUTIN,
WAS IF YOU ARE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT HAVING A DIPLOMATIC
OFF-RAMP AND WANT TO GET INTO
THAT CONVERSATION, DEET SCLAT,
SOMETHING WE HEAR FROM THE U.S.
SIDE AND EUROPEAN SIDE OVER
RECENT WEEKS.
IT'S A TEST OF RUSSIA'S
ACCIDENT.
ARE YOU KEEPING THIS DIPLOMATIC
SPACE GOING SO YOU CAN BUILD UP
FORCES?
IT SEEMS TO BE TRYING TO TEST
OUT THE RUSSIAN POSITION AND
JUST SAY LOOK, WE THINK YOU
MIGHT BE ABOUT TO INVADE, IF
YOU'RE NOT DEESCALATE AND HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION.
THAT'S THE PATH, TRYING TO GET
SOME COMMITMENT THERE.
WHEN I SAY THE DIPLOMATIC DIAL
HASN'T MOVED, RUSSIA IS NOT
GIVING VISIBILITY ON THAT AT
ALL.
>> FASCINATING.
NIC, BRINKSMANSHIP, NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
KYLIE, THE U.S. MADE CLEAR
AMERICANS NEED TO EVACUATE,
TELLING EMBASSY STAFF TO GET OUT
AS WELL.
SOUNDS LIKE THERE ARE SOME
AMERICANS REFUSING TO LEAVE.
>> A SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL REITERATED TODAY THAT
AMERICANS SHOULD LEAVE SAYING
THAT IT IS PAST TIME FOR THEM TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY, BECAUSE THEY
WARNED THAT THESE ATTACKS THAT
COULD BE COMING FROM RUSSIA
WON'T BE DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
ANYONE.
THE INCOMING AERIAL BOMBINGS
THAT ARE POSSIBLE THAT THE
UNITED STATES BELIEVES RUSSIA
WOULD BEGIN ITS CAMPAIGN WITH
COULD HIT ANYONE AND WE HAVE
HEARD THIS MULTIPLE TIMES FROM
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS FROM
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS, STATE
DEPARTMENT SAYING THEY HAVE IN
TOUCH IN RECENT DAYS WITH
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS WHO ARE
STILL IN UKRAINE.
AS YOU SAID, JIM, THEY'RE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF THOSE
AMERICANS WHO DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY URGING THEM
TO CHANGE THEIR MIND AND DO SO
BEFORE THERE COULD BE A WAR
ZONE.
THE SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL SAYING IF THERE IS A
WAR ZONE THIS DIMINISHES THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT'S CAPABILITY TO
HELP OUT ANY AMERICANS AND ALSO
MAKING IT CLEAR THEY HAVE NO
PLANS FOR A MILITARY EVACUATION
TO HELP THOSE AMERICANS STILL IN
THE COUNTRY AND WE SHOULD NOTE
THE U.S. EMBASSY HAS DRAWN DOWN
MOST OF ITS PERSONNEL, MOST OF
THE DIPLOMATS LEAVING THE
COUNTRY.
A SMALL NUMBER ARE STILL STAYING
AT THE EMBASSY IN KYEV, AND A
SMALL NUMBER STAYING IN A CITY
TO THE REST OF WEST UKRAINE,
OBVIOUSLY FURTHER AWAY FROM THE
BORDERS FROM RUSSIA TO INVADE.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT THE TATE
DEPARTMENT MADE THESE ACTIONS
AND THIS DECISION BEFORE T